story and Willard Stern Randall is
author of a new biography of Alexander
Hamilton it details the founding fathers
role in the Revolutionary War and his
influence in shaping the government of
the United States until his fatal duel
with Aaron Burr this public lives
feature is about an hour
Willard Stern Randall visiting professor
of humanities at Champlain College is
the author of 12 books including 5
biographies a former investigative in
reporter mr. Randall won the National
Magazine Award for public service from
Columbia Graduate School of Journalism
the Hillman prize the Loeb award and
three
Pulitzer Prize nominations during his
17-year career in Philadelphia
journalism after graduate studies in
history at Princeton University
Randall moved to Vermont to write
biographies his first Benjamin Franklin
and his son won a Frank Luthor Mott
Prize for research from Missouri
Graduate School of Journalism Benedict
Arnold patriot and trader was a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize and the Los
Angeles Times Book Prize and was a
notable book of the New York Times
Thomas Jefferson a life was a history
book main selection history book club
main selection was nominated for the
Pulitzer Prize and was named one of
publisher weeklies 10 best biographies
of 1993 George Washington life was
selected for Reader's Digest volume best
nonfiction of 1997 Randall recently
received the award of merit of the
American Revolution round table only
awarded twice before in 45 years he is
also a contributing editor to mhq the
quarterly magazine of military history
tonight professor Randall will tell us
about his latest biography Alexander
Hamilton a life please welcome professor
Randall
good evening of all the founding fathers
of the United States the man who might
be the most important to us today is
probably the one we know the least about
Alexander Hamilton the youngest of the
founders the face on our $10 bill spend
his whole life struggling with two great
problems war and money and the
relationship between them
as an orphan boy at 13 he thought he was
doomed to a life on a stool in a
Counting house in the Caribbean after
his father deserted him at age 9 and his
mother died at age 13 in a letter he
wrote to a young friend who had escaped
the islands and gone to New York to
study medicine
Hamilton confided I wish there was a war
he got his wish
the American Revolution he arrived on a
scholarship in New York just as the
street rioting began he signed up as a
student at King's College which would
soon have to change its name to Columbia
and there in the library at night he
pored over the writings of the French
philosophers the revolutionary tracts
written in the last 10 years before him
and turned out pamphlets that everyone
thought were written by somebody 10
years old or at least when word of
Lexington and Concord came he organized
the first militia company in New York
City which is now the oldest army unit
stealing the Canon from right under the
British officers nose is it Fort George
training students and dock workers alike
in the art
Gunnery using his knowledge of
trigonometry even though his math was so
bad that he had flunked out of the
pre-med program he distinguished himself
in the revolution by bravery at first
escaping from New York after the
Americans lost the city to the British
with only two cannon patting them like a
pet dog everywhere he went he was the
rearguard again and again for
Washington's fleeing army as it escaped
the superior forces of the British
across New York New Jersey and into
Pennsylvania no one could believe that
he was only twenty years old at the time
but Washington after seeing Hamilton and
his two guns hold off an entire British
Brigade at the Raritan River found out
who he was not that Hamilton would have
kept it a secret he had a nose for power
for patronage he always pitched his tent
right next to Washington's headquarters
until Washington noticed him at the
Battle of Trenton and again at Princeton
Hamilton distinguished himself with the
ferocity of his artillery barrages
helping to kill hundreds of Hessians and
force the surrender of a thousand of the
paid troops of the king at Princeton he
got a little revenge when he came to the
mainland he really wanted to go to
Princeton on an accelerated program but
the President of Princeton said no
nobody goes through here fast
President of Princeton was selling the
meals as well as the studies and so
Hamilton instead took himself off to
Columbia when he came back to Princeton
in 1777 with his cannon he took dead aim
at Nassau Hall and now if you take the
guided tour they'll show you the grooves
in the floor where the cannonballs came
in from Hamilton's guns the British
surrendered Hamilton joined Washington's
staff as an aide to camp this is an
office that we don't have really any
more
but basically ten or eleven of the
brightest young men in the American
colonies competed with each other for
the favor of the general they slept at
night often on the floor with their
heads in toward the fire to stay warm
but in the daytime they were the mind
and the pen of the commander-in-chief he
chose only bright young men who could
write he said he didn't have time he
told them the way he thought they were
on their own he gave it a quick look and
then he signed a model CEO as aide to
camp Hamilton took on more and more
responsibilities he became the leading
go-between with Washington's network of
some we now know 200 secret agents he
also handled prisoner of war
negotiations and exchanges among the
people that he exchanged and got out of
British prison was Ethan Allen of
Vermont more than that however he was
the writing arm the legal mind and the
man who would pull a gun and shoot at
anyone who objected to Washington or his
policies he actually rifled the files of
general Horatio gates to get the goods
on the hero of Saratoga when gates and
other officers planned a coup against
Washington
it was absolutely loyal to his commander
at the same time in other ways he was a
young man on the make he had no money he
was an orphan everyone around him was
from a leading American family good
money good connections and Hamilton knew
that most of all to get ahead in the new
nation that they were fighting to
establish he would have to marry well
Martha Washington when she arrived at
Washington's headquarters to set up the
dances and the teas around the commander
in the wintertime quickly noticed
Hamilton she also noticed a tomcat that
was pursuing every loose feline at
headquarters
she named the cat Hamilton he pursued a
variety of young women the daughter of
the Governor of New Jersey her relatives
the daughter of a major-general but
eventually he settled on Betsy Schuyler
whose father was one of the Dutch
Patroons who owned roughly one
fourteenth of New York some of the best
land along the Hudson including Albany
Saratoga Schuylerville he married into a
leading family but he never took a cent
what he wanted was the political
connection
Betsy didn't stay around headquarters
very long she was good at pouring tea
but the letters that survived are all
from Hamilton himself and they show her
as not wanting to be part of the
officers Wives scene they find find her
going back to her father constantly
living in Schuylerville raising the
children while Hamilton pursued his
military ambitions Hamilton knew that to
get ahead in the new nation from the
very beginning you had to be a war hero
and he chafed at the staff job once
again he was confined to a stool for
some five years writing the orders and
the letters of Washington he yearned for
a field command finally when Washington
made it clear that he could not spare
him Hamilton in a moment of pique said
well then I resign
he made it stick he went back to his
father-in-law's house and decided on a
law career but still he could not stay
at home he was Restless
the war was coming to an end he wanted
to be in on the last battle and at the
last moment George Washington made him
the commander of a light infantry Corps
marching on Yorktown and there in the
last battle of the revolution he let
Hamilton lead the last charge taking
redoubt number 10 which led to the fall
of the British Army when it was all over
Hamilton went home this time to study
law but there were no law books no way
to study law so he wrote one
fundamentals of New York law it is still
used by young law students it was his
way among the other lawyers studying at
the same table with him were captain
Aaron Burr and people who would become
his rivals in New York politics as a
young man in the islands filling in when
his boss got sick Hamilton had learned
about money banking Commerce and
smuggling it was good at it he
instructed the ship captains on how to
forge bills of lading and ships papers
how to get through the Spanish guards
off Cuba this came in handy when he
became the first tax collector for the
Port of New York under the New Republic
it was especially helpful when he went
on to become the first secretary of the
Treasury and it was his job to set up
the custom service so this man who
smuggled as a boy founded what is now
called the I n s Immigration and
Naturalization Service the Treasury
Department its collection agencies the
border crossings most of all though he
was he was a lawyer a writer and a
politician who wanted a strong nation he
was a nationalist an immigrant always an
outsider he had a clear picture he
thought of what the nation needed he
thought that if the nation were to
survive it would take more than the
founding fathers the soldiers the
Franklin's the diplomats would take that
second generation
it could not remain a quarrelsome string
of 13 banana republics as the original
States
were threatening and taxing each other
and not at all respected by fahren
powers when America's diplomats went to
visit the king and the foreign minister
at Versailles in those early years they
went in the order of importance of their
country the emissary from the United
States was dead last in line America was
still so unimportant Hamilton thought
that it was important for the country to
win the credit of Europe and so he set
out as he always did systematically to
study the problems of the new nation its
financial needs he soon discovered that
the new country had a pile of debts
three different kinds of debts the debts
incurred by the Continental Army the
debts incurred by the Continental
Congress and each of the individual
states put all together it was a pile of
seventy-six million dollars their money
factored that out by 41 times and you'll
see the problem while the revenues of
the Continental Congress were only a
million dollars a year so what he
decided to do was to turn America's
debts into its assets he studied the
French and the English especially the
three volumes of Jacques macare the
reformer from France and he studied the
banking system of England and he folded
the two of them together into a new
system he thought that what the nation
needed was to pay all its debtors at
once at par a hundred cents on the
dollar and create something new called a
national debt we don't think of it as an
asset now but it was Washington's
blessing upon the country because his
scheme for paying for it is what gave
the country instant credit he set up or
urged Congress
to something he called a sinking fund a
new idea where a fixed amount of the
debt of the income of the country each
year was dedicated to paying off its
national debt the nearest analogy I can
find today is that Lockbox of the Social
Security trust fund the surplus interest
of which has been used to decrease the
national debt hamilton recommended this
to congress in the first of a series of
four reports he was so little trusted by
congress that they wouldn't let him in
the room even to sit in the gallery as
they debated his plan day after day but
when it was all over the united states
had a national bank that received all
revenues mostly from customs issued all
federal paychecks mostly the Hamiltons
department he wound up with the largest
department of government at a time when
the entire federal government was
fifteen hundred men's he had a thousand
bringing in the money the army in those
days was 80 men the entire cabinet and
government was in for attached houses in
Philadelphia those were the good old
days but in addition to setting up the
first bank and creating the national
debt he found that he had to educate
everybody Congress the people the
president at every step it was a nation
of farmers and sailors ninety-five
percent of the people were engaged in
farming or selling farm goods and
shipping them to foreign customers he
had to educate Thomas Jefferson who
basically thought he knew it all and who
represented the debtor class the farmers
especially of the south and James
Madison they were afraid of his scheme
of a centralization of money and power
in one
place and behind-the-scenes Hamilton and
Jefferson worked to try to patch over
their differences they both came out of
their adjoining offices one afternoon
one hot summer afternoon in 1790 and
bumped literally bumped into each other
these two redheads sweating in the
Philadelphia Sun and heat and they
decided they had to sit down together
and so in a secret meeting the next
night they struck what is known as the
dinner table bargain in exchange for
Jefferson and Madison and the South
supporting Hamilton's plan for funding
all debts at par and establishing a
National Bank concentrating the wealth
in the north
hamilton agreed to let the capital be
built in the south in washington DC in a
new district carved out within a
horseback ride of president washington's
house within one week of the news
leaking out of Hamilton's plan the value
of stocks securities on the new york
market rose 50% and he received a letter
short after after that from Amsterdam
from the Dutch bankers that the United
States could have as much credit as any
nation in Europe what a week but
Hamilton had not only to invent a
National Bank but he had to form the
first corporation in the world he
invented the modern corporation until
that time the only corporations were
joint stock companies chartered by the
crown in England or in France usually of
charities or colonies but basically a
closed list of investors
it was Hamilton's idea to lower a
corporate veil over the identities of
investors so that anyone from anywhere
could participate in paying off the debt
of the United States investing in its
ventures in its industry
behind the veil among others was the
wife of Benedict Arnold living in
England in exile hedging her bets
getting a pension from the Queen but
putting her American inheritance into
Alexander Hamilton's bank the
corporation also or offered immunity
from prosecution for directors something
that I think a lot of people were having
a second thought about these days but to
have a bank in a corporation it was also
necessary to have money the United
States had no currency of its own nine
different currencies were fluctuating in
the United States at the time his idea
was to come up with a new currency that
instead of having on its face the ruler
the king has it been the custom for
thousands of years to have Columbia a
mythical figure and back and forth with
condor say in france he studied the
making of money coming up with a
currency that could not be cropped one
of the problems at the time as people
would snip off a little gold from one
coin snip off a little gold from another
coin it was the gold that was valuable
not the coin even the dollar was only
1/8 of a Spanish coin so Americans had
specialized in cropping coins from the
beginning and so they came up with a
decimal coin with serrated edges from
the very beginning Hamilton thought of
everything a little too much so his
colleagues became his rivals he wasn't
exactly smooth around the edges if he
didn't like the way things went in the
Tuesday afternoon cabinet meeting he
went out to a newspaper he formed that
was circulated three times a week to
attack the opponents of the government
and defend its policies Jefferson in the
same room as a cabinet member
reciprocated by forming his newspaper
the further confused the taxpayers you
had The Gazette of the United States and
the United States Gazette the editor of
one was paid from a slush fund of the
Secretary of State and the other the
salary of the other came from placing
advertisements Treasury bond notices in
his newspaper so we haven't invented
much the skullduggery the rivalries
began at the beginning but Hamilton's
dream of making the United States
solvent and creditworthy succeeded in
only one year and by the time he wrote
his final report the report on
manufacturing it was his idea that
America could grow and prosper most if
it attracted working people from Europe
and capital to start industries in
America he believed for the United
States to spread and to thrive you
needed free men not slavery factory
workers he believed would quote flock
from Europe to the United States his
prophecy of course came true between
1840 and 1913 10% of the population of
Europe migrated to the United States to
take part in its industrial revolution
to get the industrial revolution going
that he foresaw he launched some s um
the Society for establishing useful
manufacturers the first sizable
industrial undertaking in the United
States helping to build a new textile
making town called Paterson New Jersey
along the way in his five years as
Secretary of the Treasury Hamilton also
created the Coast Guard the US Navy we
had none in the revolution only state
navies and here on Lake Champlain
it took Benedict Arnold a general to
build a navy that was part of the army
to fight against the British
it wasn't until France and England both
started capturing American ships in the
Napoleonic war of the 1790s that
Hamilton this time coming back as a
Major General Inspector General of the
army as second command to George
Washington organized a sailing fleet
that augmented the Coast Guard and the
army he also radically increased the
size of the army to 10,000 men but he
clashed repeatedly with his fellow
government officials if he was so
successful in forging all these
institutions and ideas wouldn't it seem
that he was a shoe-in eventually to
become president but his genius
antagonized even terrified his rivals
especially he was at loggerheads with
Jefferson who with his friend Madison
Madison who had helped Hamilton write
the Federalist Papers together Jefferson
and Madison broke with Hamilton informed
the democratic-republicans forerunner of
the Democratic Party of today in
response
Hamilton formed the Federalist Party a
predecessor of today's republican party
then he repeatedly worked to undermine
the Federalist candidate John Adams now
one of the things that you get after
studying these founding fathers for a
while is the idea that they didn't get
along with each other and even if they
didn't show it in public they went off
and wrote the memoirs which biographers
have to struggle with and then you get a
quite different picture of John Adams
who could only say nasty things about
Alexander Hamilton and private including
calling him the baseborn
brat of a Scots peddler well baseborn
was the way they said bastard in those
days and the scots peddler part well
that's a bit of an exaggeration
Alexander Hamilton's father was the
fourth son of one of the wealthiest
Lords in Scotland Laird Hamilton but
only the oldest son could inherit in
those days so Hamilton's father had had
to do that detestable thing for any of
her Scottish Lord which was to work and
so he had learned the merchants trade
gone off to the Caribbean gone bankrupt
several times fallen in with Hamilton's
mother who didn't know that she had been
that she was still married to her first
husband until her first husband filed
for divorce without serving her with
papers and when the two of them found
out about it
Hamilton's father sailed away and he
never saw him again rather than be
indicted for bigamy he left the family
so to telescope all that into the
baseborn brat of a scotch peddler has a
little bit too economical it took more
than party loyalty or rivalry to keep
America's Merlin from becoming president
Martha Washington had it right if you
remember the cat after his marriage of
opportunity to Betsy Schuyler many
children little love
Hamilton almost certainly began a long
affair with her sister and this is one
of the things that is very hard to
document but by studying Hamilton's
account books as a lawyer you'll see
large amounts of money disappear in a
short period when he said his
sister-in-law up in an apartment in New
York City rented a carriage paid the
moving men rented a piano a few other
things totally out of character and
ended up with no cash at all at the end
of the summer
her father his father-in-law actually
had to write to her and tell her get
back to your husband
stop this and she sailed for England but
they kept up their correspondence and
that's how we can trace how long this
went on full of yearning and clever
secrets Hamilton could shift a period or
a comma in a letter that he showed his
wife that indicated his love in a code
that only he and his sister-in-law quite
understood as long as he kept it secret
but he couldn't keep his amore secret
one summer while Betsy was visiting her
father with the kids in Schuylerville
Hamilton had a visit from the wife of a
minor official in the Treasury
Department named Maria Reynolds Maria
was a very beautiful woman many men had
thought so what Hamilton did not realize
was that husband and wife were swindlers
and blackmailers and before the affair
became very well-known Thomas
Jefferson's Secretary of State James
Monroe member of Congress were staking
out Hamilton's apartment night after
night watching Maria Reynolds come and
go and eventually Hamilton took
depositions and the husband fled when he
returned he started demanding money
$1,000 $1,500 we're talking about their
money we're talking about 40,000 60,000
and our money
Hamilton couldn't keep up with the
demands but those letters to survive
when it was all over
Monroe Jefferson and Aaron Burr who
showed up as the lawyer for the wife and
the husband decided that he would have
to go public to avoid the scandal of
peculation with Treasury funds the
threat was to expose him for dipping
into the till instead Hamilton in a long
long
overly detailed confession which he paid
to publish himself in a New York
newspaper actually destroyed his chances
ever becoming president when a boom
began to make Hamilton the nominee after
Adams very unpopular first term it was
very quickly scaled squelched America
would not accept an adulterer and in
fact on the streets of New York people
knew of the two affairs and at one point
when Hamilton and his friends went out
to a rally Alexander Hamilton who had
once been in the mob at the beginning of
the revolution now himself was stoned by
the crowd Hamilton
turned back to law to New York politics
more and more he became the personal
rival of Aaron Burr and that affair
ended probably one of the other things
we know about Hamilton if we know very
little is the famous duel between Burr
and Hamilton but if we stop to think
about it
here is the great financial genius at
the founding of the country out in the
dawn in the blaring Sun on a cliff off
New Jersey having a shootout the Vice
President of the United States and the
founder our financial system it's as if
Dick Cheney went out and shot it out
with Greenspan I'm sure there are
moments when they would like to do it
but it was that shocking to Americans it
actually ended dueling in this country
New York indicted burr for murder
burr with incredible nerve fled New
Jersey went to Washington and continued
to preside over the United States Senate
eventually however after all his
possessions were impounded and auctioned
off in New York he fled to Europe where
he became the inspiration for the man
without a country he came back and lived
a long life as a New York lawyer
paramour of many a lady Hamilton died 36
hours after being shot in the side with
a 55 caliber ball from specially made
pistols dueling pistols with a foot long
barrel fired at 30 feet the pistols are
interesting they were specially made for
John Church the husband of Hamilton's
paramour his sister-in-law he provided
him first to Hamilton's oldest son who
had died in a duel three years earlier
again Hamilton used them they had
specially made hair triggers Hamilton
wrote that he had no intention of
killing burr he just wanted an affair of
Honor he probably intended to fire in
the air Aaron Burr had no such intention
he set the hair triggers he fired first
the hair trigger works with the
slightest pressure it takes more force
to pull the trigger without it burr is
shot was deadly Hamilton's broke a tweak
in a tree and that was the end of
Alexander Hamilton 36 hours later his
wife and his mistress at his bedside the
man who founded our financial system
died he was only 49 years old thank you
very much
I hope we have some questions I'm not
disappointed sir would you wait for the
microphone to be brought up we have
someone bringing the mic up the center
aisle yeah on the subject of the duel
and I can't remember where I read it I
thought I read in the boat on the way
back Alexander Hamilton said be careful
my gun not been fired yet so there was
some speculation that he didn't even
think he fired his gun is is that
something you read about her I think his
exact words were be careful the hair
trigger is set so he thought it hadn't
been fired and that the hair trigger was
on it I think from reading the accounts
of the seconds on both sides that he was
hit so hard so quickly that he didn't
know whether he had fired or not as best
I can tell but he had they went back
later and they actually climbed the tree
and found the broken bow and then traced
where the bullet had gone so he had
fired but it was like this after he was
struck by burrs bullet
I'm from Saratoga Springs New York I
grew up there and I spent a lot of time
in Schuylerville in that surrounding
area what what happened afterwards
through the Schuyler family is his
former wife sister-in-law her family
have you done any research on that
that's a very good question
Betsy Schuyler lived another 50 years 50
years spending about 35 years trying to
find the ideal biographer somebody who
would tell the story pretty much the way
she wanted and told she also destroyed
any of her letters to Hamilton we would
love to see the other side of that
correspondence they had a rough time
most of the Schuyler land was most of
Schuyler money was in land which was not
the great treasure of Americans at the
time there was just too much of it for
sale so there wasn't much income there
wasn't much cash the tenants weren't
paying so as it turned out
Hamilton wasn't worth anything as much
as he thought there wasn't much to leave
to Betsy and Betsy had slow income from
her own rental properties
she had slave labor on her property
Hamilton had never owned slaves he had
grown up in the Sugar islands of the
Caribbean surrounded by them and he
detested that institution and he's
really caught on the horns between
slavery and women's rights he can't tell
her to get rid of her property her
slaves so she went on using slave labor
immigrant labor she managed to make a
living and she made the house a shrine
the home that he had built a shrine with
a magnificent bust of Hamilton right in
the drawing room
the Schuyler family generally had more
land than money from that time on but
she held on her son John John Church
Hamilton whom Hamilton had named after
the man who provided the pistols
ultimately wrote a biography that was
very one-sided very Pro Hamilton so she
protected his image ironically she's the
one that made him the hero
after his duplicity with her and years
later there's a wonderful scene where
ex-president now former President James
Monroe comes through Schuylerville and
stops to pay a social call on Betsy
Schuyler Hamilton and she wouldn't
receive him she wouldn't let him sit
down even she said after the part you
played with my husband you do not even
stay he was the man in the carriage he
was the man taking the notes on the
Maria Reynolds scandal so she was a
tough lady and she held on for another
50 years safeguarding his reputation by
the way his reputation used to be much
greater than it is now and I think what
happened to that was the Great
Depression Americans looking for a
scapegoat for the collapse of the stock
market blamed the man who had created it
but as long as she was alive she
safeguarded his reputation sir
he was he was supposed to be actually of
course he um fascitis um of course he
was it was apparently supposed to have
been very brilliant very fast learner
you came up from from a humble
background till as you said of course
they were to be at twenty was he was
really in charge to allow very
responsible person with me well
education was pretty irregular in those
days at best but Hamilton sort of broke
all records first of all on the in the
islands especially on st. croix where
his mother went to raise him and his
younger brother and run a store to
support him he was not allowed to go to
the government school st. croix was in
the Danish West Indies which were
reformed Calvinist Protestant and no
illegitimate children were allowed
either in the schools or a church or
communion so he actually went to a small
private school where the other group
that was not allowed into public school
Jewish children and so by the age of
five he could recite the Decalogue in
Hebrew while holding his mother's hand
at our recital he had no formal
schooling after that but his mother
taught him French his mother was a
French Huguenot her father was a
Huguenot refugee from France so he
learned in addition to some Hebrew a lot
of French which would come in very handy
as the main interpreter between
Washington and the French officers
during the revolution his French was
impeccable it also made him the closest
friend of marquis de lafayette so
whatever he did he did well he had he
had a very interesting tick he learned
to memorize by saying everything out
loud so when he got his scholarship for
helping out as employers business he got
a scholarship to New Jersey he was sent
to Elizabethtown Academy which was the
prep school for Princeton at the time
and he already had enough Latin and
Greek to sail through but he would go
out in the graveyard behind the church
in the school
every morning with his cards with the
grammar words and the syntax and he
would recite them out loud as he paced
back and forth and people remembered
that when the revolution came because he
was the only one of Washington's staff
who was walking around reciting the
letter that he just wrote but he would
consign things to memory that way I
think this helps to explain the the
incredible output that the man had he
could hold those facts for years he
studied geography when he was 20 that he
put to work when he was Secretary of
Treasury 20 years later and he could
write prodigiously not only beautifully
but prodigiously Washington the way
Washington ran his cabinet was each week
to give them a problem his cabinet
members and they had seven or ten or
fifteen days depending on the complexity
of the task to turn in a written report
well when Hamilton wanted his bank
Jefferson opposed it Jefferson was no
slouch as a writer
Jefferson finished on time and turned
his report in Washington as a courtesy
said mr. Hamilton why don't you cast
your eye over this and see what do you
think well he paced and muttered and
paced and muttered for a week and then
in three days he wrote 15,000 words the
report on the bank which is the
foundation of a financial system it blew
Jefferson away
the back there
huh this makes him someone of a bland
question but you said about to get the
money nowadays what it was worth then
are you factored by 41 I had finished
the Washington biography and every time
you converted money
it didn't seem like very much because
Washington seemed like he was such like
a wealthy known as a wealthy individual
and maybe because of his land but it
seemed like something was missing maybe
it was because of a because of the money
wasn't just distributed the distribution
of wealth wasn't so much that the case
because nothing seemed he didn't seem as
wealthy as so nowadays a famous
well-known
man of power that's certainly not a
bland question and one of the hard parts
about doing books like these is to try
to find out the value of things first of
all Washington's wealth was in land as a
boy he had found his father's surveying
tools in a shed after his father died
another orphan and learned to do
surveying and for the rest of his life
wherever he went and no matter who was
paying him he picked out the prime land
until he owned 35,000 acres of
riverfront land including the entire
town of Charleston West Virginia
which is named after his brother Charles
10 miles of the Potomac now that's worth
a little something 10 miles above the
Potomac where he built Mount Vernon his
wealth was in land the other thing we
had a barter economy clergymen were paid
in firewood and chickens so were school
teachers just firewood farmers knew how
to buy things without leaving a paper
trail even then for tax purposes
smuggling was the chief industry in
Vermont even when Jefferson declared an
embargo that's why we have Smuggler's
notch so you're not going to find as
much wealth on the record but even if
you could the average income of an
American in 1789 the average was only
four hundred and thirty-seven dollars
something like a very poor third world
country today if you factor that out is
still only about six thousand dollars
our money
that was the big problem that Hamilton
faced with the national debt the other
thing is only about 20 percent of the
people could vote and were full citizens
and pay taxes so out of two and a half
million people when the country began
only a hundred and sixty thousand had
the vote
the problem is takes 76 million dollars
their money divided by 160,000 and you
have this two or three times what the
vast majority of Americans made to pay
off and that's why his scheme of
attracting foreign investment was so
brilliant but the numbers seem very
small but then the other thing to
remember is the disparity between what
workers and farmers make now and what
CEOs pay themselves is far greater than
any other country in the world at any
other time and that's a very recent
phenomenon it used to be maybe thirty to
one in Japan it's only twenty to one not
a thousand to one
so wealth was not as lavish the rewards
were not as lavish at that time as they
are now Chris
hi well getting back famous dinner table
conversation between Jefferson and
Hamilton where Hamilton offered the
capital of Washington for the relinquish
enough ond's how widely were those bonds
held by a limited number of people or
many people how widely were the bonds
held at the beginning that's been a
subject of a lot of political
controversy over the years very widely
not just by speculators in New York and
New Jersey who had held the bonds before
the funding of the national debt but for
example loyalists like Benedict Arnold's
wife in England the French bought in
very heavily even though they hadn't
been paid their debts or even the
officers their pensions this was seen as
a great investment opportunity so
anybody who had cash could buy into that
and it was pretty generally held very
very quickly the stock market was at
first only on a curb was known as the
curbside market in front of a Tavern on
Wall Street but it couldn't handle the
volume pretty soon you had stock
exchanges in New York Philadelphia
Baltimore so it rapidly expanded we have
a question back here with sue Miller
thank you I was a little confused about
your description of his being stoned in
New York was it the city of New York at
that time Oh were they not mostly
farmers around that and living in that
area over there trades people how can
you describe a little who stoned him and
I would think you know that that he
would have a lot of sympathetic
understanding among some of the
wealthier people well that's a very good
question but the city of New York in
1800 still mostly had unpaved streets
with pigs running through until somebody
who had the job caught them and and
butchered them it was small probably
thirty five thousand people hardly
deserves the name of city but it had no
police force no town or city in America
had a police force and when a crowd got
together and got an idea into its head
it usually did what it wanted Hamilton
had been on the side that had thrown
stones even though he hadn't personally
I think at the beginning of the
revolution but he now had become
establishment he had become the
government he had become the voice of
money and burrs people were the artisans
the dock workers the the whole situation
had turned around until when he went to
a rally during an election with just a
few of his Federalist friends very
well-dressed gentleman and stood in the
doorway listening to the political
speeches he was instantly recognized and
the crowd turned around and began
yelling things at him personally and
stoned him and actually somebody hit him
with a rock in the head and opened quite
a cut and he decided was a good time to
get out of there so it wasn't a ritual
stoning for adultery as might happen in
some countries at the time or even now
but he was so unpopular that he became
the light
for popular protest sir
we have you mentioned that he author of
some of the Federalist Papers with he a
large factor in the framing of the
Constitution he was a larger factor in
the ratification of it than the framing
he was the delegate one of three
delegates from New York to the
Constitutional Convention of 1787 in
Philadelphia but the other two were
appointed by Governor George Clinton of
New York who was an anti federalists and
who was opposed to central government
opposed to a new Constitution wanted to
keep the Articles of Confederation and
the power in the state and so he packed
the delegation with rivals of Hamilton's
Hamilton tried to get his father-in-law
to go with him but that was defeated in
the New York Senate so he was outvoted
the voting was by state by block and so
Hamilton knew that whatever he did it
wouldn't make a difference in the vote
because it wouldn't be counted but he
couldn't stay quiet he sat there and
first he got himself on this committee
then he got himself on another committee
till he was controlling the agenda he
only spoke once when he could take it no
more without voting he stood up and
without any notes he expounded for six
hours in the summer heat of Philadelphia
might have made him a few more enemies
but for six hours his note sat on the
table the notes survived in his papers
and it's really the outline of the
government of the United States it's all
in their checks and balances executive
branch legislative branch federal
judiciary which still didn't exist no
federal judges sounded off and went home
and discussed well they brought him back
in time for the signing and he decided
at that point that he would go out and
champion the cause so he and Madison and
John Jay decided together to write
letters to the New York press in defense
of the Constitution
I wrote a few and then got sick and sort
of fluffed off Madison concentrated on
theory of government especially from the
writings of Montesquieu and the French
philosophers whereas Hamilton went right
to the core of could the country survive
without a strong central government what
would it take and he did two-thirds of
the letters himself putting aside his
law practice that's the thing here's the
man surrounded by all this money and he
died really poor heavily in debt not all
from philandering by a long shot not
taking any money from his father-in-law
going off for months or years on these
Crusades in Congress or the
Constitutional Convention without taking
any money so yes he was a strong factor
in its survival but not in its actual
writing Madison was the voice the father
of it if somebody in the back row
I was curious when you mentioned about
his smuggling as a young younger man
when he was starting the I ns and the
other arms of those governments customs
and such how effective were they
and based on takes one to know one
perhaps and how different may have been
from other countries or places that were
establishing those types of systems I
think it was the cliche would be more of
Fox in charge of the henhouse he knew
all the tricks and he appointed customs
collectors in America had hundreds of
small ports at the time and it was a
sieve for goods coming in or out that's
what kept the revolution alive huge
amounts of war materials being brought
in by the French and he knew about that
too so what he did was set up a
reporting system that every one of his
Customs collectors had to report to him
in writing every week and he gave them
detailed questions I mean it was it may
have been a political plumb to begin
with but it was an anvil around your
neck after a while but he gathered data
that supported the laws that he got
passed by Congress to tighten the
controls decided after that there was
need for a Coast Guard decided that
there was need for lighthouses one
purpose is not to prevent shipwrecks but
to watch smugglers
he knew the tricks and he set up a very
effective net against smuggling because
all of the revenue of the United States
in the beginning was from customs duties
he couldn't get any other taxes through
he tried to put a tax on whiskey and he
wound up with the whiskey rebellion
because people on the frontier knew that
the cheapest way to transport liquor was
either in a barrel or inside yourself
the grain was too heavy so there was
almost a war over that so he went back
to the idea of promoting trade enabling
trade protecting the importer and the
exporter with court cases that he took
on himself
and then from them gathering the revenue
for the new country
well sir no more questions thank you
very much for coming out on such a cold
night
Willard Stern Randall is author of
Alexander Hamilton a life it's published
by HarperCollins on the web at
HarperCollins com